congratulations Thank You wonderful film
you guys were fabulous thank you I was
on set and I remember you both saying
that you're quite a big fan of the book
so I'm curious as performance what was
the scene you were most excited to
realize and what were you kind of
nervous and dreading a little bit mm-hmm
I think they're for me they're one in
the same time which is that my favorite
section in the in the book is where
rachel is for the first time revealing
to Lois about what it was like growing
up with her ill sister and that and that
to me is one of the the most specific
and acute the acutely aware scenes of
what grief is because she's just an on
this rollercoaster it's not just like
crying it's like laughing and maniacal
and anger and all of these things all at
once which is to me what the grieving
process is like so I was I was really
interested in exploring that but it also
has a performer I was like I don't know
if I can do that I don't know if I can
actually like emote all of that all in
once but but yeah so that was the season
I was scared of and also interested in
exploring hmm good couple of you this
coming this is couple of big sequences
in there that they were very there's a
lot of pressure to try and find them you
know and even in the fact that we didn't
know what was the right version of them
you know the one being particularly when
you know Amy meets you know her daughter
for the first time he's come back you
know it was and then there's other scene
that we shot between you know when you
go upstairs after you met her so this
the color they're not really in the book
properly you know he's moved on from
that and we're doing that sort of
explaining what's going on you know
which is which was terrifying because
that's that's one of the big jumps in
the film you can really lose the
audience there where you can you can
make more wrong than right so I was not
always out of my mind about those scenes
but you know I'm sure watching them last
night
that must have been fun with that crowd
they were eating yeah there was really
it's very confronting you like okay yep
yep yep your things are going on in this
you know that's the first time I'd seen
really you're watching a lot of things
but it was really good to see people get
hit and feel comfortable about letting
it out you know you know it's you should
go around all these different festivals
and different crowds of different
energies and there was a wonderful
energy in this in this genre horror film
you know Stephen King loving universe
it's like a it's like a wonderful warm
fun blanket it's a very impassioned
community it really is you know it
really is
and for the best of all possible means
in this world that we live in absolutely
it's funny that that would come from
horror yeah well that's I find them some
of the biggest cinephiles are horror
genre films and right now Edgar Allen
Poe yeah I mean is such a wonderful to
get that it's such a big history
tradition of it in America
I've looked great writing in that of fun
riding in that tongue-in-cheek but but
dark as well to explain it in a way that
you know is not all you know clean but
it's messy and you know Sleepy Hollow I
mean it's extraordinary you know yeah
and there's a huge tradition of some of
the best filmmakers starting it was such
a pleasure